[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
john barry espn
radio nba analyst the former nba player
on the call last night game one
hawks bucks what do you think of
fritzy's analogy there that trey young
needs to be more like cinderella
if they are a true cinderella steward uh
intriguing okay um i i kind of like it
i mean it's like i think the knicks fans
have made him into a villain he wasn't
like this before
and i guess he's so upset uh but
he's got a right to do whatever the hell
he wants right now with what he's doing
explain this to me though the buck's
defensive philosophy
against trey young you know he's going
to shoot he took 34 shots he missed 17.
but these pick and rolls are
you know tell me what you think
milwaukee was trying to do
and now what adjustments can they make
in game two
dan he's taken 87 field goal attempts in
his last three games
87 uh relentless energy i i
it's amazing i mean he's kind of
reminding me now
allen iverson excuse me uh well i think
what the bucks did originally
is that they said we're not going to let
their three-point shooters get going
and we're going to live with trey young
coming off the high screen and roll
our big is going to retreat and we're
going to give up the floater
and that's what he got early in the game
he i think he had 12 or 15 points early
and they were all on floaters he was
over three from three
and so they're going to give up that
floater and not give up threes
second quarter jeff teague came in the
game he went
under the screen twice and trae young
hit two threes
and that really got him going that was a
huge mistake now
it's not going to really show up in the
box but in the nba playoffs when you
have
when you're supposed to do something and
you don't do it one time your coach is
going to be mad the second time
you're going to sit down and you're not
going to return to the game if you're
jft
and that's exactly what happened he
didn't come back in the game in the
second half
so the play is it's it's unbelievably
hard to stop i mean
what other play in the nba playoffs is
better than that
throughout these three rounds other than
jay crowder
to deandre ayton throwing it into the
rim from out of bounds there's no better
play
than what's going on so they tried to
switch it in the second half they went
small
the bucks did and what happened
offensive rebounds jon collins and
capela crushed him on the glass because
they went small so to me
they trapped as well at times and i
think that was the best thing that they
did i don't think they did that enough
that's what i would do i got to get the
ball out of this guy's hands and make
somebody else shoot the ball to beat me
but you played against john stockton you
knew john was a pass first point guard
this is these point guards now these
guards now
like they're they're not looking you
know
dame lillard steph when when they come
off the pick
they want to shoot it um ben simmons
um wanting to shoot i'm joking
oh okay it's early uh surely
sure um you're right but trey
trey does a good job i mean he's going
to read that big if that big
retreats he's going to go ahead and
shoot the floater
and if the big comes up he does a great
job of wrap around passage to the big or
the lob pass to collins or capella
i mean he is as smart as they come
coming off that high screen and roll he
uses a burst of speed to make that big
make a commitment
and uh i mean he's torturing people with
this play and last night
certainly wasn't any different a couple
of my guys earlier this morning we were
looking at the uh the shimmy
by trey young and a couple of my guys
said he was just
resetting like he had time to reset and
i go no no no no
he's saying oh no one out here i'm gonna
give you a little of this
and then i'm gonna stick a stick a
jumper right in your mug do you think
that he was
you know kind of having a little bit of
fun a steph curry
moment for trae young last night man you
know
he created so much space it was
unbelievable i mean drew holiday got
turned around
you remember scott brooks back in the
day when he was with the knicks and he
got turned around
by alan iverson i mean it was one of the
funniest things i've ever seen
like he created about 12 feet of space
and
i think he was more surprised that he
was that open i mean
i think it was john collins that was
close to him and nobody
even made it i know no one even made a
run at him i mean so he was just kind of
like
and and as shooters know that typically
is a harder shot right when you have all
the time in the world
yeah and no one's coming at you because
he never gets that uh and he's still
knocked it in
i think people have a heart i think
people look at steph curry as more
polarizing
because he did the shimmy and the
mouthpiece and the whole thing like that
i said trey young's got to win more to
become
polarizing i think there's still a
fascination somebody that
size is able to do what he's doing would
you say that's a fair assessment of trey
yeah i think yeah um it was funny like
two weeks ago i'm sitting at the men's
grill and
we're talking luca doncic trae young
and two weeks ago i just said it's not
even close who i who i'd rather have
now uh the guy's delivering
and you can say what you want about both
players and
this guy is i mean the play what he's
doing in the playoffs is unbelievable
okay who would you rather build around i
if i give you a tray i give you luca
okay i'm i'm still leaning luca okay
but as these playoffs continue to go on
this guy's making a case what i don't
understand why don't any of these teams
go at him defensively did you see last
night
he had one possession where he got to
giannis got switched on you honestly
he looked around like wait why am i
guarding somebody where the hell is my
team
come over here and get him off get me
off of him
and that's what atlanta does a great job
of whenever he gets in a situation
where he's got to really guard somebody
they come out and bail him out
but i can go at him obviously you can't
do with pj tucker
but put him in some pick and rolls and
see if you can get him to switch and and
try to take advantage of him
i don't like the greek freak bringing
the ball up to court
am i nitpicking here john i i hate it
when we've seen it what year after
year him at the top of the key at some
point with a defense
built to stop him from getting to the
paint
and guys that can't make shots the
three-point shooting from milwaukee they
were 31 percent coming into tonight in
the playoffs
or last night they shot 22 last night
eight for 36.
i mean middleton goes oh for nine um i
like when he's on
the mid or on the baseline 15 feet out
very difficult to double team there he
went baseline a couple times where it
looked like he was going out of bounds
and reached over and dumped the ball i
mean
that's the good that's a good spot for
yons to be i don't like the top either
talking to john barry the espn radio nba
analyst uh he was on the call
game one last night the eastern
conference finals on espn radio hawks
and the bucks chris paul is probable for
tonight's game
wouldn't he either be cleared or not
cleared to play
like it sounds a little
gray that he's probable for tonight's
game well i
i think phoenix is putting that out
there just to leave some doubt
i mean that's what all these coaches do
is we're not going to give you anything
i mean we do our zoom calls in the
morning and i ask well what's the match
up here who's going to get
well i can't tell you like what who do
you think i what am i going to do
i'm not going out there to guard him you
don't have to worry about it
so yeah i think he yeah he's either in
or out they know right now
whether he's in or out right yeah
i i would assume that he would be
anything from the nba that he's being
told when he's allowed to play so
they know i don't know why the nba
doesn't say this is the day that
chris paul becomes available because
there is a day
and also watching that inbounds pass if
you look at the clippers
defensive strategy there boogie cousins
i think is playing for a pick and pop
for devon booker
and and he's not even thinking about an
alley-oop and
and even when he's there he can't jump
anymore and so he just got his arms up
and i mean it was a great call by monty
williams
i i just questioned what the clippers
were looking at john or
expecting well i don't know why i and i
i actually said i was here in milwaukee
and i was at italian restaurant
with the three officials that did the
game last night
so they hand the ball to crowder and i
see where zubot says i'm like
what is zubot's doing what do where do
you think deandre is going
he's going to the rim yeah so he should
have been just standing
right at the rim anything that gets
thrown there jump as high as you can and
knock it away
he's standing there so he allows himself
to get back screened by booker
and then but tomb is guarding booker
he doesn't step over and stop ayton's
progress to get to the rim i mean
he at least has to do that and then if
booker look if he does a derrick fisher
and catches it throws it in from
you know the free-throw line you got to
live with that that's a hell of a lot
harder than letting deandre just go up
there and touch a ball
and knock it in but that was very
important clearly the clippers had no
idea
that you can throw the ball up in the
rim and there's no offensive bolt in
there because
10 of them went like waving their middle
finger like oh that's goaltending
well no it's not you just lost and you
probably lost the series on that play
alone
but we've seen losses like this where
do you think it's more devastating when
you lose like that or if you get blown
out by
35 points to try to rebound if you're
the clippers
i i i think i i don't know that's tough
uh i i think i'd rather lose like that
at least i had a shot to win the game
so i got my butt kicked right i mean
they should have won the game paul
george minister's
freeze froze i mean he's a mid 80 free
thrift shooter there's
if he makes them both they more than
likely win the game so
i'd rather say that well hey guys we did
enough to win this game
you know you're not going to tell your
team well because paul missed two free
throws
but they they did enough to win and but
the problem is is that you
say if chris paul comes back this is a
far better phoenix suns team now
with him and kawhi leonard doesn't seem
to be coming through that door
now you played for both milwaukee and
atlanta all right
i did yeah they came up to me last night
and said that
well they did like real
96 97 you guys lost to the bulls didn't
you
we did we beat them in game one and
celebrated like
a championship and uh and jordan saw us
in the ho
in the tunnel from that way he goes okay
that'll be that four straight
hey it's great to talk to you and uh do
you have game two
yeah i got them all oh good okay
how was the atmosphere last night
a lot of murmurs you know uh until they
got
up they were up seven with four minutes
to go
and then i think they felt like they had
it and then
crashing down i'll tell you what
milwaukee
does not play very intelligent
basketball at times
shot selection clint capela got an
offensive rebound with
i don't know 30 seconds ago they were
down one how do you not follow clint
capela
three guys are around them and they let
them lay the ball in
that just can't happen i mean stuff like
that you gotta you gotta know that
that's not
mike boonholzer that's those guys having
a recognition of
he's a 44 free throw shooter i'm not
letting him lay it in to take the lead
inside a minute of the game and also you
ben you were in the nba for such a long
period of time you could see where young
teams
they don't know that they're not
supposed to you know win this game like
atlanta feels like
we don't know better we're just out here
playing nate mcmillan's done whatever
nate has done
he's done a wonderful job with this
hawks team because
they're emboldened like you're not
you're winning road playoff games
three consecutives they're not afraid of
anybody here yeah
uh six road wins six and two three game
ones on the road a game seven on the
road
um it's impressive i don't know what
exactly he's doing i think he's been
great for trae young
it seemed like this is the first time
trey young has ever been coached as he
got
that job early in the season where trey
took a 35-footer that wasn't on the
drawing board
and nate mcmillan called him over and
screamed him screamed at him
uh he's done great for him but yeah this
team has just got some moxie they're
tough
and my son texted me last night my
oldest
and i rarely agree with him but he said
don't
think we can keep making excuses as to
why the hawks win
they're just good and i i tend to agree
that i i'm a believer they're they're
they're pretty good they're doing a lot
with bob donovich
guys essentially he's hurting their team
by the way right he's hurt
he's doing nothing and they're still
getting it done i mean it's it's quite a
run
and phoenix at the same time right this
you win 19 games
two years ago you don't go into the
playoffs for the first time
in 10 years and go to the finals and
potentially win
i mean it's it's it's an amazing run by
both of these squads
great to talk to you bud thanks for
joining us thanks bud
that's uh john berry espn radio analyst
he'll be on the call eastern conference
finals hawks
and the buck